I don't like my money going my tax money
going to support the war in Iraq I don't
like it buying Humvees in the first
place but I really don't like it buying
Humvees that are not armored armor
protected for our soldiers a lot of it
is would I take food out of the mouths
of piles of orphans and clothes off the
back of people living in an assisted
care institution to give two artists no
I wouldn't is it as high a priority as
global warming or the fight for a cure
for AIDS or war on poverty or anything
no I wouldn't argue that it is but our
government does a lot of things and it
spends money on many things that are far
more frivolous in fact I don't think art
is frivolous at all but we spend money
on things that are truly frivolous while
art is seen as a frivolous expenditure
and if you're thinking about money as
stimulus you don't have to look very far
to see the effect that the Arts have a
positive effect that arts have on on the
financial health of
of our country more people go to see art
in the museum's of New York City then
then attend all sporting goods sporting
events combined and more money is spent
on admission to art museums than all
those sporting events put together
notwithstanding the two-hundred-dollar a
seed price of going to a yankee game and
ten dollars to get into the to get into
them tomo we bring more tourism into the
city than all those sporting of the
sporting events and more people come
here and stay in hotels to see theater
ballet opera and attend art museums then
come here for conventions so we are we
are valuable to the communities in which
we exist directly financially every
dollar spent in the arts has about a
hundred dollars in return in terms of
the way it moves through a society with
its hotel rooms and the people who are
making the beds and the people who are
carrying the luggage and the bartenders
and the bars and the people run the
restaurants that dollar recirculates
about a hundred times so I would suggest
that that it's an investment that our
government could justify in terms of how
it kick-starts the economy that it is
truly leveraged and that is the
stimulant that are that our economy
needs